autre grand moment quand partagent
ensemble dans aller les quelques
dernières minutes qu'il nous reste à
passer ensemble avant de retrouver votre
tous 13,7 avec tiphaine en est en train
de déguster tout à l'heure un petit peu
de produits italiens là on va déguster
d'autres très belles choses sont des
livres des livres qui sentent bon les
vacances après la charcuterie ça sent
bon les vacances et ça sent bon la
lecture vous nous avez réservé quoi s'il
vous plaît je crois qu'on commence pas
repartir en voiture oui directement
allez je vous emmène avec guillerme
carsten et ce très joli album pour les
tout-petits publié au seuil jeunesse
alors l'histoire c'est un surfeur qui
rêve de prendre la vague mais en chemin
il est attendri par des auto stoppeurs
qui est aussi veulent partir à la mer
alors c'est des auto stoppeurs un peu
particulier si vous voulez bien un
plongeur un super héros un alligator et
même le petit chaperon rouge figurez
vous ah ça c'est pas mal c'est pas vous
avez bryce de nice et le petit chaperon
rouge parce qu'il ya un surfer qui
cherchent se baladent dans la nature
alors imaginez que voilà le voyage
commence à être un peu mouvementée ils
sont au moins 10 dans cette petite
voiture et du coup ils arrivent ils
arrivent plein plein d' aventure alors
c'est un livre sympa parce que c'est une
petite ritournelle avec des rimes et ça
plaira aux enfants en plus c'est très
coloré
voilà donc je le conseille pour les tout
petits c'est sympa à les premiers
conseils lecture on va en avoir quatre
aujourd'hui
ça vous va comme ça très très bien aller
en continu sur la route des vacances on
a un coffre grands ouverts on va
rajouter un autre livre pour nos enfants
qu'est ce que vous nous conseillez tiff
alors je vous conseille d'en mener votre
chien en vacances elle appelle les
vacances de mon amie carla de stéphane
qui laissait publié par grasset jeunesse
est alors carla je voulais dit j'ai un
petit peu vendu la mèche c'est un chien
un chien dehors une chaîne va là et
figurez vous qu'elle attend depuis un an
les grandes vacances parce que les
grandes vacances c'est le moment où est
bien une passe toutes ses journées avec
sa petite maîtresse on peut aller voilà
à la plage on peut aller à la piscine on
peut aller à la montagne et dans cet
album qui est aussi très coloré et bien
découvre tout ce qu'on peut faire
pendant les vacances avec bien son
meilleur ami à quatre pattes ça c'est
pas mal c'est à partir de 5 ans voilà et
c'est très joli j'ai une petite
parenthèse pour ceux qui nous rejoignent
on en parlait tout à l'heure avec jérémy
quand on a parlé de vacances solidaires
faut pas oublier nos amis à quatre
pattes ne faut surtout pas les 1
on en parlera mercredi on partira avec
en stop notre veto car l'année n'est pas
la seule arrivée de vacances non alors
je sais pas si vous vous souvenez à la
rentrée dernière je vous avais parlé une
petite héroïne de clotilde de la croix
eh bien figurez-vous qu'elle détestait
l'école alors si on me déteste l'école
en général on adore les grandes vacances
et en lozère dans champs pendant un an
alors ces livres là ça s'appelle maman
les vacances et moi et c'est publié
aussi aux séries jeunesse est alors
vraiment c'est très très drôle je vous
le conseille
l'idée c'est voilà de suivre ses
vacances avec cette petite héroïne et sa
maman alors les vacances c'est le moment
où on fait la grasse matinée
on n'est pas obligés de s'habiller pas
tous les jours
ça peut jouer des tours vous le verrez
mais par contre on a un petit peu ranger
sa chambre quand même parce qu'en
général c'est le moment du grand ménage
et on attend les d'aller à la mer
parfois alors on envoie des signaux et
c'est pareil voilà alors c'est un livre
très sympa qui montre parfois le
décalage entre la vision des adultes et
celle des enfants par exemple vous allez
dans un château encore convenu les
enfants votre avis alors c'est une bonne
question
en général c'est le voyage en train ou
la propreté des toilettes
enfin voila je le conseille aux jeunes
lecteurs parce que ils pourront se
moquer de leurs parents et puis de même
aller pour terminer un livre avec un
petit peu d'humour noir on va dire que
c'est pour pour les ados c'est un peu
plus grand oui alors c'est s'appelle et
comment c'est comme ça qu'on a décidé de
tuer mon oncle alors là c'est vraiment
de l'humour noir c'est de roanne o'grady
c'est publié dans une toute nouvelle
maison d'édition qui s'appelle toussaint
aventure c'est aussi pour ça que je
voulais vous en parler et l'histoire ses
deux jeunes enfants alors barnaby et
christie ils partent en vacances sur une
île de colombie-britannique et ne se
connaissent pas et finalement il décide
de monter un complot pour tuer un oncle
un petit peu particulier
alors je vous le conseille c'est
vraiment très sympa ça a été créé en 63
et ça na pali un parfum de vacances avec
les conseils lecture de typhaine qui
nous a accompagné cette année et qui
reviendra l'année prochaine avec
d'autres judicieux conseils comme à
chaque fois je suis pas très très
inquiet un aussi joli chapeau que ça
dites donc ça doit faire dévier l'eau
cela et ça me ferait trop nombreux
j'adore moi je jouais pas montré la
couverture du dernier livre lettres vous
avez vu c'est un petit pas fonda
commence avec un bel animal et les
fleurs autour du cou
dites moi vous avez appris la lecture à
quel âge ou thyssen a aussi payé comme
un petit peu tous les enfants que croit
à priori à priori il existe